uh
okay so hey you know who's just like us
bree larson's just like us but roy she's
not just like us
yeah she's she's sad and dead on the
inside she really is just like us
oh yeah good point uh so she's doing
these just
these are funny little youtube videos
where this is an eight-minute commercial
for an air fryer
it's called but will it airfry
hello youtube it was great the first
time so i'm back at it
again for part two she's not attractive
i've come to that
i'm done with it she's not attractive
but will it air fry
once again i will be exploring the
concept of breakfast lunch and dinner
to see what is the best and the worst
out there to fry to start breakfast
we have a fine selection we have a
classic frosted brown sugar
cinnamon pop tart she's never eaten
those in her life this is the first time
she's doing it for this commercial
we have the true pride and joy
of my life the toaster strudel
and we have an uncured turkey bacon
we're going to see what happens i think
i should put
this this is a commercial
and begin for the air fryer for the air
fryer yes
cool what is happening to her
this is a yes
ah
that's terrible that's terrible
i i can tell that's terrible and she's
faking it
see how mushy that was truly one of the
great things that exists on this earth
at this time
12 out of 10 100 would recommend oh my
god with the meme talk
everyone talks like this now
well it's chewy oh it's not supposed to
be all mushy and chilly
okay this is also a yes the outside is
supposed to be
like crispy and flaky a little bit and
then like the inside it shouldn't just
be a mush bag
so it shouldn't be a cake
that will be fun too okay we'll see
the final act is here i hope this video
ends with a [ __ ] structure fire
is served hey daiya pizza
looking pretty delightful
tomatoes look good too none of that
looks good
also why is your air fryer in your
living room because it's a better place
to
film it for this commercial i mean
honestly like isn't it isn't it
off-putting doesn't the whole thing just
throw you off like why are you cooking
in your living room
this looks like something a college kid
does like he thinks he came that came up
with a new genius [ __ ]
hey bro check it out so i put an air
fryer on my night on my
[ __ ] coffee table so now i can make
bagel bites while i'm playing halo
nice reminded me of something that i
don't quite know what it is yet but
maybe one day i'll find out because i'm
gonna have to make it again
probably right now immediately because i
want more and i want to understand
although the toaster strudel got the
most points today
i really want to give she's just
throwing anything in the wall to see
what sticks like you she doesn't even
know what she wants
she's a gamer she's talking about
diddling herself
i mean what what what are you bree do
you have any personality that's your own
no she never did or do you just watch
other youtubers and go i'll just copy
what this person's doing
about an hour setting please
like this video so that i can make one
what
wonderful opportunity to eat all three
meals
in about an hour setting
please like this video so that i can
make one
okay hope you're happy and safe in your
body bye-bye
huh
there's no way this video only has 116
down votes i refuse to believe that
huh
it's such a good i i like bree she does
really original content
you know